[Music]
foreign
let's start with the government this
morning just a few moments ago I spoke
to the chair of the conservative party
that's Greg hands
the RCN has rejected the government's
payoffer and they plan to escape strikes
now we know you don't want them to
strike but I just want to start by being
clear about how high you think the
stakes here are
well everything lives are going to be
lost as a consequence of this strike
well I think it would be a serious
strike and it will be a challenge but
can I just pick you up on one thing the
RCN leadership effectively recommended
the payoffer it's the RCN membership
that voted narrowly uh to reject it
there are still other unions that are
out there still balancing at the moment
uh Unison the largest Health Service
Union which represents I think a third
of all agenda for change staff that's
the staff affected has voted in favor so
let's wait and see where the other
ballots come in yeah what uh you're
right about the size of Unison but that
represents all uh Health Service staff
as you say but there are half a million
nurses who have voted narrowly or not
they have voted to reject the offer and
I really want to just get started by
being clear about what we think the cost
of this might be especially if it is a
escalated into what is now being called
the mega strike where several different
disputes coordinate to strike on the
same day Junior doctors and so on and so
forth how serious do you think this is
going to be well look I think the public
uh very concerned understandably and we
will do everything that we can and I'm
sure the NHS management the NHS will do
everything that it can to make sure that
uh that the impact of the strike is kept
under control but I I wouldn't be being
truthful if I didn't say it will have an
impact a nurse is going on strike it
will clearly have an impact but we think
that we've made a fair and reasonable
offer four percent last year five
percent this year plus lump sum payments
starting at 1 250 that is why the RCN
leadership and Unison and other unions
have actually recommended this offer to
their memberships but let's be clear you
are not going to do anything
further on the offer to avert a possible
strike you are not budging that's your
fight that's a full and final offer it
is a full of vinel offer but we are
waiting for the other results to come in
uh from the other unions let's say
Unison the Lord
when you say you're waiting for the
others to come in does that do you mean
you're waiting for the others to come in
because what you might do depending on
the results of the GMB ballot and so on
you might decide to vary the offer or
are you just hoping that the others will
vote to accept the offer and the RCN
will be isolated which one is it well
it's it is a full and final offer but
equally it's only reasonable for us
we've been accepted uh the offer has
been accepted by Unison recommended by
the RCM but not accepted by its
membership is only reasonable for ours
during the middle of the balancing
process to wait to see those further
results and we'll be laying out a
responsible to be meeting with the NHS
staff unions as well to make sure that
we can take that forward but the
position is that we're waiting to see
what the other results are at the moment
and we just urge everybody this is a
very very reasonable offer it's fair to
it's fair to NHS workers it's fair to
other public sector workers and it's
fair to the taxpayer so just to be
absolutely clear and I don't want to say
that what you said is interesting
because what you'll immediately do is
say no I didn't say that but what I hear
here is a government that says
this is our full and final offer
but
in a new situation there may be more
talking to be done well look Steve
Barkley has said that his door is always
open uh
um so long as in particular answered a
preconditions or strikes taking place
you know we are willing to talk but this
has been something which has been
thrashed out with the unions themselves
this four percent then five percent
offer 1 250 minimum it's a very very
reasonable offer Trevor so both you um
both you under the the RCN leadership
clearly misjudged the temper of the
members but what I'm hearing you saying
here is that the government is not set
in concrete it is willing to talk
depending on what the uh broad the broad
set of results in these ballots were all
turned out to be I mean Steve Barkley is
always willing to talk so long as there
aren't preconditions attached and so
long as there isn't the threat of
strikes going on at the moment uh but as
I say this is a fair and reasonable
offer
um that has been accepted by Unison as
being balloted by others has been
accepted by Unison represent like a
third of the agenda for change staff I
mean it's a big part of it all right
look
um
Richie sunac was supposed to be all
about quiet effective Administration
getting stuff done
um but now we've got doctors and strike
nurses on strike civil servants
balloting teachers balloting again rail
workers out there walking off the job
um now what all these outfits have in
common is that they are ultimately in
the pay of the government it doesn't
really Inspire confidence when your own
employees basically are walking off the
job well I don't agree with that I think
Rishi sunak is doing a very good job
overall he's laid out his five
priorities of halving inflation uh
cutting the debt growing the economy
reducing Hospital waiting is stopping
the boats those are the people's
priorities that is what Rishi sunak is
getting on with I'm letting you repeat
this the slogan but my point is you're
not going to be able to do any of that
if all your employees are out on strike
and here's your problem
parents can't be sure that schools are
going to be open commuters can't be sure
that there's going to be a train that
gets them to work the patients can't be
sure they'll get their operation we pay
our taxes to make sure that you the
government keep these basic Services
going and frankly yeah I know you want
to say it's somebody else's fault but
actually that's what we pay you for and
you're not doing the job why shouldn't
we vote for you in a couple of weeks
time because I think the government is
delivering on overall where the people
want us to be delivering on it's
obviously difficult times no one's
pretending this job is in any way easy
the inflation that has been Unleashed by
Vladimir Putin's illegal and appalling
invasion of Ukraine again you're blaming
this on Vladimir Putin well I'm blaming
inflation Vladimir Putin didn't vote in
the ballot it's your negotiation or
failure I'm blaming Vladimir Putin and
the increase in Energy prices which is
what has driven inflation in the first
place that is why inflation is such a
high priority for the government the
halving inflation is absolutely one of
our five priorities that is if you like
the backdrop for why there are
increasing pay demands is to keep Pace
with inflation and the inflation is
obviously driven the UK is not alone in
this our inflation rate is it is other
countries are also facing very high
inflation similar issues with uh let's
just give this one more go the nurses
did not declare war on Ukraine the
teachers haven't negotiated the rise in
oil on on in Energy prices this is
supposed to be your job and all of the
people uh that you pay who you employ
basically are
cross with you let's put it that way and
they are walking oh good job but that's
a failure of you as an employer I don't
agree with that Trevor actually because
when you look at uh what's going on in
the NHS for example uh there's six
unions at the moment balancing as I
already mentioned Unison which
represents uh the largest part about a
one-third of the agenda of a change
staff their members have accepted
there's other uh unions balloting at the
moment the RCN leadership implicitly
recommended the offer so the the
position or the situation is much more
nuanced than you are than you are
suggesting that actually the government
is delivering we're delivering what I
think are fair offers uh to public
sector workers a four percent last year
five percent this year in the case of
NHS staff minimum payments one one-off
lump sum payment of at least 1 250
pounds that I think most people out
there will agree is a reasonable we've
gone over that but I mean I would say
that you're also delivering uh late
train and school closures uh and also uh
delayed appointments and operations and
that's your responsibility not everybody
else well it's our one of our priorities
is to get to grips with the NHS waiting
list and you're right that the strikes
do not make it any easier Bringing Down
the NHS waiting list but nonetheless
that is what we are fixed on that is
what Steve Barkley that's what the prime
minister is fixed on is one of the five
priorities reducing NHS waiting lists
right we're treating her um has said
this morning uh to us that he thinks
that effectively the RCN are in the
wrong
in their decision not to provide cover
for emergencies uh do you agree with him
well look I think we'd like to see uh
the management of the NHS make sure that
the impact of the strike be effectively
made as as as as minimal as it can be
notwithstanding this will have will have
an impact
um but we're relying on the management
there to deliver a good program of care
you're not willing to say that this is
an ethically a wrong thing to do well
it's it's my job is to at the moment I'm
waiting to see the results of the other
ballots yeah I'm not getting into
criticizing specific people how they
behave I want trying to get a resolution
and Steve Barkley and the Prime Minister
trying to get a resolution to this
dispute but as I say we're waiting for
the other ballot results to come in all
right well very diplomatic let's talk
about the other big news from this week
um
presence Biden's brief visit to Belfast
um the dup leader to Jeffrey Donaldson
said it doesn't change the political
dynamic in Northern Ireland we know what
needs to happen and he is not going back
to Stormont
um so what's the point of this visit
well I think the point of the visit was
to recognize
um 25 years the anniversary of the
brilliant Good Friday agreement that's
why Rishi sunak was in Belfast then as
well was to recognize what has been an
anniversary which has delivered a lot
for the people of Northern Ireland
obviously we want to see the power
sharing government back executive back
in place in Stormont as soon as possible
we've done what I think is a really good
deal on the Windsor framework to solve
that issue of the flow of goods from
Great Britain to Northern Ireland a very
pragmatic uh solution-based approach
from Rishi soon I'm finding solutions to
problems getting a good negotiation good
relationship with both the European
Union and with President Biden and with
the Irish government that is where the
solution lies okay but the dup isn't
going back you need the Stormwind
assembly up and running because there
are issues in education there are issues
in health and all of that's got to be
dealt with
when you're going to bow to the
inevitable and either opt for direct
rule or fresh elections well you can't
keep sitting forgive me on your hands
and saying oh something's going to
happen you've got a responsibility to
the people of Northern Ireland we do
have a responsibility to people in
Northern Ireland and the people of
Northern Ireland very much need the um
government installment to be back up and
running and the dup to re-enter
government that is what the government
our government is urging everybody to do
to come back together the Windsor
framework we think offers a very good
and workable solution to many of the
issues that have been raised now is the
time to get a devolve government back up
and running but that's work in progress
all right let's talk about your pledges
and the big one there is stop the boats
um the Home Secretary was on this
program recently and she said uh this I
think we're making tangible process in a
short period of time but ultimately yes
you'll judge us on our record
uh let's have a look at her record
um she says Judge Me by my record I'm
I'm going to ignore the stream of horror
that's emerging from our police forces
at the moment and just focus on
immigration
um prime minister stop the boat but
there's still thousands across making
the crossing each week there is a deal
with Albania but there have been almost
no illegal Crossing uh migrant from
Albania returned to to Tirana nobody has
been put on a plane to Rwanda anytime uh
so far and that's not going to happen
anytime soon unless you can tell me
differently tomorrow
um if you are judging the Home Secretary
what would you be getting this morning D
plus maybe well first of all Trevor
there have been returns to Albania yeah
tiny numbers well we're we're talking
about 15 000 people who've crossed and
the numbers are handfuls come on well
we're getting on with that and the agree
dream of an Albania of course was only
signed relatively recently and by
working with Albania It's a combination
driver taking the sort of tough action
the legislation going through Parliament
which labor and the other opposition
parties have opposed at every point to
make sure that we've got the laws in
place to deal with the boats we've got
the agreement with Rwanda that is
working its way through there's been
appeals in the courts to try and stop
that we're working through those appeals
we've got the agreement with Albania
we've got the agreement with France
again set by a much better relationship
between Rishi sunak and the French
President Emmanuel macal we've got the
agreement with Rwanda we are getting on
with it but you know it is work in
progress again
there's a lot of work here for lawyers
aren't aren't there and there's a lot of
paper shuffling uh moving between here
and there the one thing that isn't
moving is uh illegal migrants back to
where they came from well that that is
why we're putting through the
legislation that's why we're reaching
these agreements with friends and allies
as diverse as Albania France Rwanda it's
actually really getting the government
getting to grips with this issue which
is exactly what we're doing both British
sunak and Suarez well look I mean don't
take my word for it let's look at what
the country uh thinks
um when Sola Brahman first came to
office in September last year
um 76 of the public thought you're doing
a bad job
today in spite of all you've done
telling me about you know the agreement
you've made and all the rest of it
83 of the public think you're doing an
atrocious job you are the party chair
um you need to do something don't you I
mean isn't it time to put soella Brahman
out of her misery reshuffle her to
somewhere else not at all not at all
she's doing a very good job and it is
about 83 don't agree with you okay but
what people have spoken but I've already
outlined Trevor how we're getting to
grips with the job and how we are
passing the legislation how we are
coming to these agreements with key
allies but sometimes these things will
take time and that is why for example we
are starting returns to Albania we are
getting into grips about it and Sue Ella
is right on top of it all right well
look um
you know the Judgment isn't mine and it
isn't yours the judgment is going to at
least or some part of the judgment is
going to be made in less than 20 days
time when you are sending your troops
into a local election uh ballot
um
here is the the national picture of
voting intention and I think what it
will show us is that there is a pretty
consistent uh lead for labor of course
it's been coming off the boil recently
you can I know you'll tell me that and
so on but this is pretty awful for you
isn't it well no one was pretending it's
going to be easy last year was a very
difficult year for the country a
difficult year for the government a
difficult year for the conservative
party but what we are doing is Trevor is
getting on with the five priorities of
halving inflation restoring growth
cutting the debt reducing Hospital
waiting lists and stopping the boats
that is those are the people's
priorities those are Rishi sunax
priorities in terms of the local
elections these before principally on
local issues we've got some there's a
huge number of conservative councilors
up for re-election uh in a few weeks
time uh the conservatives Remain the
largest party of local government the
independent expectations are that labor
the conservatives will lose more than a
thousand seats and that labor need to
make big gains that is what the
expectation is out there okay but I've
been up and down the country that
consumers were fighting really hard I've
got some great counts you're predicting
a thousand seat loss are you just trying
to massage our expectations here that is
what the independent experts professors
Rollings and Thrasher uh John Curtis are
all predicting I'm saying we are
fighting really hard we've got some
great counselors great Council
candidates up and down the country have
been traveling up and down the country
the last couple of weeks all the way
from Ramsgate to Hartlepool from
Pickerington to to Worcester campaign
okay I've let I've let you do that but
um this is odd you're a thousand seats
and you see them rather sanguine about
that um that sort of shellicking in the
past usually leads to a sacrifice of
some kind and the prime candidate is
always the party chairman
um
after local elections uh
are you going to be the person who's
going to come in and defend the tonking
that you will have had still do you
think or will Mr sunac move you on but
let's see Trevor but what I would say is
that those are those are the independent
predictions from the uh the most
credible academic sources that the
conservatives are likely to lose a
thousand seats I'm campaigning really
hard I've got some brilliant counselors
and great candidates about fighting this
is really saying conservative Council
this is really peculiar if I were a
Conservative candidate in those
elections watching this program now and
I hope that they they all are I'd be
expecting a bit of Boris johnsonism here
I'd be expecting you to say we'll be out
there we'll be uh eating into Labor's
campaign but there's no this thousand
seats uh that that they're gonna gonna
lose it's all nonsense we are on but
you're telling them you know what it's
going to be pretty awful no I'm telling
I'm telling them because I've been
meeting with them seeing them up and
down the country in recent weeks that
actually the conservatives are fighting
hard conservative councils deliver
better they cost you less tax 80 pounds
less tax on council tax delivering
better Services better pot better action
on potholes lower crime in conservative
areas these are all kind of real
tangible deliveries by conservative
councils councilors Council Canada can I
just ask you one one last quick quick
Point
um
I'm sure that inside conservative buddy
headquarters uh you are you know you're
lowering our expectations but I think uh
you're detecting some signs of Hope in
Nepal
um
help
if the former prime minister's Boris
Johnson and Liz truss who have been
making speeches defending their records
uh recently uh would you welcome a
period of Silence from both of them well
actually in the conservative party we're
the most important thing is getting on
with the job of governance rather than
um kind of these uh um Westminster sort
of political machinations that is what
Rishi sunak is is focused on he is
focused on the five priorities that we
laid out earlier this year delivering on
those five priorities okay well that
sounds to me like a clear message to Mr
Johnson mistrust take a holiday uh Greg
hands thank you very much
that was the conservative party chair
Greg hands well let's get the view from
labor now with another critical period
for the NHS looming earlier I spoke to
the party's Shadow Health secretary
where's streeting
the nursing members of Unison which is a
labor sporting unions have accepted the
latest offer from the government but of
course despite the advice from their own
leaders the RCN members are rejected it
are you disappointed by that I want to
enter this dispute like everyone else
we've still got two more unions who are
out balloting their members on the deal
so we wait and see what they say
um you know without speaking for the RCN
that's their job my sense from talking
to members who've been voting in this
ballot is the result that they've cast I
think reflects the depth of anger with
the government some of the rhetoric
we've seen from government ministers
during the dispute you know one point
um saying that nurses were helping
Vladimir Putin by going on strike I
think that sort of rhetoric hasn't
helped and my fear is that and I hope
this dispute is resolved imminently for
this year my fear is we're going to end
straight back here for the coming years
pay round so I think what the government
need to do more than anything else
actually is to give NHS staff some sense
of light at the end of the tunnel so
we're not back here month after month
year after year because reading the
headlines about a year of industrial
action patients can't afford it the NHS
can't afford it I actually don't think
staff themselves can afford it in terms
of the pay they lose so we've got to
have a resolution that's that's the
government but um for once the
opposition could have an influence here
would you like to take this opportunity
to appeal to our team members to follow
their Unison colleagues and think again
well they've obviously had their vote
one thing I would say to RCN they're
talking about an escalation of the
dispute through the manner of the strike
action they've taken I think one of the
reasons why the RCN has enjoyed
widespread public support is that in
previous rounds of industrial action
they have been gone out of their way in
fact to say look we're going to protect
emergency care we're going to protect
Cancer Care and I'm deeply worried about
the risk of escalation of the nature of
their dispute to remove what none of the
derogations the measures they put in
place protect those areas of care I'd
appeal to them if they are going on
strike again to continue to protect
patient care because with the junior
doctors strikes this week we'll see what
the actual impact of that was in the
coming days but I am really worried
about patient safety actually in the
middle of all of this so for absolute
Clarity you think it would be wrong for
the RCN to escalate by removing uh the
protect the protection for emergency
life-saving care that they uh extended
in previous strikes yeah there just
aren't circumstances in which I'm going
to sit on your program and say I think
it's right to remove cover for emergency
care for Cancer Care I think that would
be the wrong thing to do I think the
government have got to now
um you know bend over backwards to
resolve the disputes not just in
relation to nurses by the way but Junior
doctors because they're making the same
mistakes all over again we saw months
and months of no negotiation with
nursing which led to disruption but also
a tremendous amount of bad will and bad
feeling towards the government in the
nursing profession they're making the
same mistakes all over again with Junior
doctors now where even after four days
of strike action this week which was far
more disruptive than the nurses strike
there are still no negotiations and I
cannot for the life of me understand why
today we've got the health secretary
writing in the sun saying he's worried
about patient safety well you know it's
no point writing to a news newspaper
like an Agony Aunt you're the health
secretary show some leadership well
let's talk let's talk about that the
student doctor's pay demands around
about 35 percent
it'll cost one uh 1.65 billion gross uh
Labor's always very keen to tell the
government to get around the table let's
suppose you're the health secretary and
you're around this mythical table
would you accept the 35 uh
Demand Being on the table would you
accept that that something that you
would negotiate at that level well I've
been very upfront with the BMA and
saying that a 35 demand is not something
that I would be able to deliver if I
were the health secretary today
around the table because they're saying
they're not coming to the table unless
the 35 percent is on the table I'm not
sure that they are saying that I heard
them on the time
to be fair of the BMA and we're not
always on critical of each other I think
what they've said is they've made their
35 pay claim they've explained why
they've reached that figure but they
what they have said is they're not
setting preconditions for talks and I
think one of the things that we've
surely got to have learned from the
nurses strike is don't set preconditions
for talks just sit around the table and
talk and negotiate and let's see if you
can try and meet someone the
government's position of no compromise
and the bmas position which is 35 but
willingness to come so this is a message
to the junior doctors which is to say
drop the insistence that the government
must have the 35 quote on the table and
to the government uh drop all
preconditions basically what you're
saying is everybody stop saying I've
come to the table if yes drop
preconditions just sit down and
negotiate because it's not in patients
interest for this disruptions continue
it's also not in the interests of Staff
you know NHS staff on picket lines do
not want to be there they want to be at
work serving their patients what they do
want I think is fair pay and some light
at the end of the tunnel that the
terrible conditions they're working in
the NHS are going to improve in the
foreseeable future and I think it's that
sense of hopelessness and Desperation
that's been reflected in the balance
results that we're seeing um now uh the
the the doctors have been pretty clear
about uh what they what they want you've
also been clear that a labor government
would demand reform if
it were
dealing with the situation now
um the uh one of the doctors leaders BMA
chair Philip Banfield was on this
program a few weeks ago um here's what
he said about you he said I met with
West streeting this week and we had to
agree to disagree that he doesn't
understand general practice uh labor has
a lot of work to do between now and an
election we've offered to help them with
that and we'll do business with anyone
who has the right policies now um
do you feel any more clued up about
general practice uh since you've met him
has he given you a little seminar let me
tell you what I see in general practice
which is despite a million more
appointments being provided by GP since
pre-pandemic levels we still have a
situation where people are struggling to
get access to a GP still scrambling to
get through at 8am in the morning to
book an appointment as if we're still
living in the 20th century rather than
the 21st
and people often especially those with
ongoing medical conditions uh
struggling to see not just a doctor but
the same doctor for that continuity of
care
and we've got to change the situation
for patients primarily but also for
people working in general practice so I
think are increasingly burned out and
demoralized and what I see in the NHS at
the moment as a system is the worst of
all worlds which is we do late diagnosis
which means both more expensive and less
effective if I'm going to say so you're
telling me about diagnosis what you want
to do but what we want to do is shift
the focus of healthcare out of the
hospital into the community more Primary
Care to do that of course you need to
have the staff that's why we've
committed to the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history doubling the number
of medical school places as the NHS has
asked for as well as increasing nursing
and referee clinical training place and
a whole range of other staff roles okay
because unless we've got the doctors we
need we're not going to get all right
working on time I know you're going to
tell me that you'll pay for that with a
non-dong tax
um just very quickly
um the non-dom tax by my Reckoning is
now paying for your seven and a half
thousand doctors it's also paying for
breakfast clubs in schools I think it's
also paying for um police officers now
of course you can get into a room and
fight with Yvette Cooper that's the two
two things
how much is this uh this is a kind of
magical expanding no it's not isn't it
no it's not I'm glad you asked this
question so two things it's paying for
it's paying for the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history 1.6 billion pounds
is paying for the expansion of Primary
School breakfast clubs to every primary
school and that's met within the more
than three billion pound spending yeah
that that provides and all of Labor's
policies at the next election are going
to be fully closed and the windfall tax
is paying for everything else is it the
windfall tax is obviously paying for
measures to help with people's energy
bills which is the right thing to do
okay and there is a running theme here
Trevor which is not only are our
policies fully costed and fully funded
but there's fairness baked into how we
pay for it because under the
conservatives we've got the worst of all
worlds which is working people being
clobbered with higher taxes that they
can't really afford and we've gone from
low growth to zero growth in the economy
under the conservatives okay okay there
is question about whether there'll be
any non-doms left because the numbers
are shrinking everything oh come on we
always hear them if I come taxes on
working people let's go effortlessly but
the moment you say let's ask people with
broad shoulders to pay the conservatives
start crying
they can't afford it I mean Cry Me a
River I'm just I'm just making an
observation that the numbers of are
shrinking 10 year by year because every
time you say we're going to tax you they
decide not to come here let's talk about
let's talk about Labor zones let's talk
about Labor Zone campaign um
put out this ad campaign attacking Rishi
sunak uh on a series of fronts
um
was that a mistake no here we are here
here we are I mean do you genuinely you
wear streeting do you genuinely believe
that that man there thinks that adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children should not go should not go to
prison well if you believe that no don't
tell me what you what you meant do you
believe that well if he doesn't believe
that no no
we'll ask where she's doing that because
he lets four and a half thousand adults
convicted of sexually assaulting
children under 16. no no you're giving
17 I'm asking you you've met this guy do
you think he actually thinks that people
who have sexually assaulted children
I'd like to believe that the answer is
no but look at the Fig the figures speak
for themselves why is he allowing this
to happen and it's perfectly reasonable
to challenge a conservative prime
minister on the abysmal failure of 13
years no no you you keep Sliding Away
From what your poster says which is that
this guy thinks that people who have
assaulted well there are only should not
should not go to prison tell me answer
to this question do you think he thinks
that or do you not think he thinks that
well I have to assume that he thinks
that because otherwise it's either it's
either that or incompetencies
either he thinks it either he thinks it
which is bad or he doesn't think it but
isn't doing anything about it which is
equally bad either he's got the wrong uh
policies and principles or he's just
incompetent and can't deliver and either
I think is a problem for the prime
minister of the country and labor is
absolutely right to take the gloves off
and hold the government's account for 13
years of appalling failure on Law and
Order in the economy in our Public
Services nothing is working properly in
this country after 13 years of
conservative government and we're right
to hold them over the course
set out an alternative you say Labor's
taking off the gloves let's um look at
what that um well-known softy labor
formal over Home Secretary David
blunkett said he said when I heard
yesterday about a tweet from the labor
party's official account suggesting that
Rishi sunak was somehow responsible for
failing to lock up criminals who had
abused children I immediately thought my
party is better than this uh David
blunkett well-known
you know kind of soft-hearted uh
wouldn't would never get into the ring
with the opposition come on why come on
this is an opportunity for you to say
look this was a mistake I don't think it
was a mistake at all absolutely
there's more to come there's more to
come we're going to get more of this are
we yep we're good robustly holding the
government to account for 13 years of
failure and Rishi sunak doesn't get away
with coming in at the last minute
through as to replace yet another
failing conservative prime minister to
pretend that somehow he's a clean slate
that he's different from everything
that's come before because we've had now
enough chances enough Prime Ministers
under the conservative party what we
haven't got are results that deliver for
the country and we're right to hold them
to account and right to set out a labor
alternative we're interested in thank
you very much thanks have me
well more to come watch this space
well as usual the take will follow this
program just after 9 30. it's our chance
to analyze today's interviews and talk
through any news lines with our Deputy
political editor Sam coats
but we can get a quick take from Sam now
on what stood out to him so far this
morning
um good morning Sam what have you made
of the interviews so far
uh good morning Trevor nobody said it
would be easy that with the words of
Greg hands when you were interviewing
him just a moment ago as he talked up
data from Sky's election analyst Michael
Thrasher pointing to the conservatives
having potentially a thousand seat loss
in the upcoming general elections with
labor on course to win 700 seats but of
course what's interesting is talking to
many people in conservative circles
that's exactly what they're doing
they're seeing the odd green shoot after
a good few weeks for Rishi sunak with
that deal over the Northern Ireland
brexit uh settlement and his trip to San
Diego his meetings with President Biden
things just seem to be looking up for
him but what your interview this morning
did I think Trevor showed quite
effectively is that when it comes to
delivering on key things particularly
those strikes and those flights back to
Rwanda the government is still stuck
with no resolution in sight there's not
really going to be a kind of Tory
recovery a substantial Tory recovery
until they fix the problems that a hit
people hard every week
I I was very struck so he I mean you
expect a conservative party chairman at
this point to be saying you know we're
we're all this Doom and Gloom it's
mistaken we're hearing on the doorsteps
that everybody loves us it's all gonna
be great Greg hands I mean I know I
don't do this all every week but this
seems a completely new tactic here
I mean I just think we're at the point
of pre-election pre-election hearing
where uh you do have to try and make out
your party might not do as well uh uh as
they could uh because you don't want to
seem like you did worse on the day on
Election Day then people were
anticipating the conservatives have a
lot of seats to defend at this upcoming
election uh in May it's the biggest of
the four-year local election cycle so
there's a lot at stake the joys didn't
do well at the equivalent elections in
2019 uh but we will be Rishi sudak's
first moment where he is tested at The
Ballot Box that's why they're trying to
calibrate the expectation so carefully
okay thanks and we'll talk a bit more
later on
you're watching Sophie Ridge on Sunday
with me Trevor Phillips still to come
this morning
a little later I'll speak to the former
Irish Prime Minister Bertie Ahern
and then we'll hear from Nicola McKee
Corner she's the sister of Lira McKee
the young Northern Irish journalist
gunned down by terrorists
[Music]
first though let's turn back to the
plight of the National Health Service on
Friday two major unions were split on
the payoffer from the government Unison
the biggest union accepted but the Royal
College of Nursing members rejected it
that means yet more nurses strikes next
up over May bank holiday for 48 hours
and including emergency care and that in
addition to the increasingly bitter
dispute with Junior doctors
so how will the NHS cope with the now
deepening strike crisis
the NHS Confederation represents the
Whole Health Care system in England
Wales and Northern Ireland and its chief
executive Matthew Taylor joins me now
good morning Matthew
morning how serious is the risk to life
being posed by the strikes that we can
see coming ahead
well there are two elements that I think
are particularly concerning to us the
first is the RCN are excluding from
derogation derogation is the way in
which the trade unions agree that they
will cover certain
key areas that are involved in
protecting life from them and the RCN
have said that some of those errors will
not be covered in that x-ray that
includes for example Emergency Services
and we're also concerned about the
speculation of the possibility of a
combination of Junior doctors and nurses
actions so both of these things would be
a significant
escalation and it's very difficult to
see how either of those things wouldn't
uh endanger patient safety and dignity
you're saying that you think that
specifically because of these tactics
there is a an elevated risk that people
will die
yes I think that that that the whole
point about escalating industrial action
is it becomes tougher tougher to handle
it's it's time to send
a stronger message it's important to
recognize that that we understand the
anger of nurses we understand the anger
of of Junior doctors and they're
concerned not just about pay
but about conditions of work
but in relation to both the disputes uh
in terms of Junior doctors on a travel
we called last week for a cast to be
involved because there seems to be no
basis to the junior doctors and the
government to talk to each other BMA of
agreed to that we encourage the
government now to call in a class so at
least talks can start
in relation to the RCN
um as you know the trade unions the NHS
trade unions work together as a group
through their NHS staff Council Unison
voted in favor of this deal we have to
hear from any other unions unite GMB and
others and we would
encourage the nurses to wait until we
have the collective view of the NHS
trade unions before deciding what to do
next
hope I think both on the government side
and possibly even amongst some uh people
within the RCN that the votes that will
will hear the results of this week will
change the situation and that in
practice what we'll
what will turn out is that irrespective
of the RCN ballot that actually uh the
money will will end up that they'll vote
to accept and that uh the money will end
up in people's pay packets and things
will settle down but I just want to
stick for a moment with this issue of
the uh abandonment of derogations
is there a sense in which we are now in
a very dangerous situation in which
if you like the ethical boundaries of uh
the industrial relations conflict have
been broken in some way that the things
that everybody would accept or
previously accepted as a boundary Beyond
which you you do not pass has now been
erased
well certainly uh as I said Trevor when
we're talking about escalation when
we're talking about the derogations that
are being respected in the past uh being
excluded in this industrial action so
that it does affect for example
uh emergency uh services and when we're
talking about the possibility of
combined industrial action this type
does take us into uh Uncharted Territory
and it means that the people that I
represent will have to spend a great
deal of time doing the detail planning
the detailed negotiation with trade
unions locally to try to ensure that we
can protect life and limb so so none of
this is welcome so however much we
sympathize with the case of the doctors
and the nurses and however much we
continue to press the government for a
proper Workforce plan something to be
arguing for for years and continues to
be delayed we do want to avoid this
industrial action because the other
thing I think I'd say from is it is yes
we can focus on what happens on those
days of industrial action I was in a
hospital last week the hospital was
coping pretty well in terms of emergency
cover with the junior doctors on strike
but I spoke to surgeons on the surgical
award at the Consultants there they were
keeping things going but they were aware
that every day more people were being
added to their lists because of canceled
outpatients appointments and canceled
operations and that harm that kind of
harm that comes from people having a
canceled operation a canceled
appointment it may not be immediately
life-threatening but it can still have a
huge impact on people
your members are essentially trying to
uh if if you like ameliorate the impact
of these actions and uh over time uh
things stack up and so on and so forth
is there a point Beyond which
essentially you can't do belt and braces
you can't bootstrap where actually the
service collapses
I don't think the service will collapse
I think that the NHS throughout its
history
you know as we approach its 70th
birthday you know I think we we cope
with anything that has thrown us but are
we able to provide the level of service
that we want no we're not and as the
nurses and Junior doctors would point
out this is the case even when we don't
have strike action so whilst we've seen
some good figures last week we're
reducing the people who've had to wait
more than 18 months for operation to
almost zero there's been an improvement
in Diagnostics hitting some keep getting
coaches some key cancer treatment
targets you know we also heard last week
of what 10 of people waited more than 12
hours to be seen in emergency
departments so you know the NHS has been
run down it's been underfunded
particularly in relation to capital
investment in terms of Workforce so
we're not always able to provide the
care that we want but we are able to
make progress I think what's
heartbreaking for the people I represent
is that they're doing that work they're
making inroads they're seeing progress
we're starting to get closer to our
targets and then these days of
industrial action really knock us back
let's let's suppose that we actually at
some point do get a settlement let's say
in the next few months
how long do you think it will take the
NHS to recover from the disruption of
the last year
what was as I said we are starting to
make uh progress I think with a fair
wind
um if the industrial action wasn't
taking place we would continue to make
that progress and I think a critical
thing now Trevor is preparing for next
winter Europe as your you know viewers
will will recall we've had a really very
very tough winter we had a combination
of flu and covid and and
situations and parts of the Health
Service that none of us wanted to see
so I think we've got to make further
inroads into those people who've been
waiting a long time to be seen and we've
also got to do the preparation and and
have a better winter so that we are able
to continue to make progress I'm
confident about the NHS in the medium
term if we get the resources if we get
that Workforce plan
but it's tough because every day travel
we have to meet high levels of demand
driven I think like by things like
population uh aging public health
challenges at the same time as making
inroads into that backlog and that is a
difficult job day in day out but it
becomes almost impossible when you're
dealing with industrial reaction as well
Matthew Taylor thank you very much for
your time this morning thank you
on his arrival in Belfast for Good
Friday agreement negotiations back in
1998. Tony Blair said it wasn't the time
for sound bites but that he felt the
hand of history on his shoulder
he'd been mocked for that but it was of
course a truly historical achievement by
all involved and this week leaders
passed and present including President
Biden have been marking the 25th
anniversary
Bertie Ahern was the Irish prime
minister at the time and won The
Architects of the agreement but with
Stormont deadlocked he says it now needs
to be reviewed
buddy Hearn joins me now
good morning Mr Hearn
good morning Trevor
um Now American presidential visits to
Ireland now seem to take on the flavor
almost of pilgrimages
um what do you think this one actually
achieved
well I think the president of the United
States of America or that matters most
heads of state are always very welcome
in in Ireland
um I think President Biden for you know
50 years has been a very good friend of
Ireland in all his roles down through
the years he's been here many times he's
been here twice as vice president and
um I I think you know that he addressed
the doll building up that relationship
with the parliamentarians of today you
know moving around the country as he did
from Northern Ireland to the Border
counties where his relatives come from
to the west of Ireland and and meeting
fairly well you know huge amounts of
people from various organizations you
know that strengthens our you know
contact with the United States which is
hugely important also as you know and
the enormous amount of American firms
that are in Ireland a huge amount of
investment that we receive from from
America and the amount of Irish
companies that are now operating in
America very successfully
well
evidence affections for Ireland
um playing as it is hasn't uh all
entirely been taken in a positive way
here he said that the UK should work
more closely with Ireland's support the
people of Northern Ireland what do you
suppose he meant by that remark
well I suppose he he was referring back
to the fact that prior to Rishi sunic
there was very little contact between
the Irish government and the British
government and the institutions of the
Good Friday agreement and particularly
the British Irish Council and hadn't met
for a long period
success of prime ministers hadn't
attended I think the last one that
attended before Rishi sunak's attention
attendance in November was Gordon Brown
and you know it was your last interview
who's got that must have been back 13 14
years ago so I'm sure he was referring
to that because it was a bit odd quite
frankly that countries that are so close
together
um couldn't get a British prime minister
to attend a British Irish
intergovernmental Council for that
length of time
but I I think you of all people uh will
will understand the sensitivities here
the former first minister of Northern
Ireland Arlene Foster says that Joe
Biden I'm quoting here hates the United
Kingdom
um do you think that there's some part
of him that is basically anti-british
no I don't I don't um isn't he working
very closely with the British government
and Ukraine isn't there non-stop
contacts between the British government
and the United States and you know we
have to live in the Years where we found
it very difficult Trevor uh to get
um involvement from the United States
that didn't go through the British
government and there was a time that we
were told when I was younger that
Northern Ireland was none of our
business that was totally
um UK matter now thankfully we've all
matured and got a bit of sense and cop
on and moved on from those days and so
you know nowadays thankfully there is
dialogue and we've built up
relationships but you know I I think it
is good for President Biden to remind
people that that's the way it should be
um
I know that you're you're um a legendary
Diplomat in many ways but I'm sensing
that behind this is a sigh of relief
that Boris Johnson is no longer in
number 10 Downing Street
no it's it's to be honest it it doesn't
really matter driver to me who's the
prime minister of United Kingdom is
that's a matter for the United Kingdom
but you'll appreciate and that we found
it very difficult to deal with Boris he
he seems to be a very colorful guy and a
very nice guy but you know we had the
trouble with the backstop with the
trouble with the protocol we had a lot
of trouble with brexit in the first
place uh quite frankly I don't think we
would have had the institutions in
Northern Ireland down
um on and off for the last six or seven
years if it hadn't been for brexit in
this course of some told difficulties
and problems but you know we we try in
Ireland to live in the future we try and
get on with things and you know I think
what we now need to do issue soon
actress prime minister he has really
done a good job in in our estimation
here in the last six months he has
invigorated the efforts to get
everything working in Northern Ireland a
huge amount of positives to come out to
the Good Friday agreement it's not just
it terms of of the you know the peace
but an enormous amount of the the
various part of the agreement the
legislation the demilitarization you
know dealing with the prisoners you know
dealing with so many of the north south
issues have have gone away and we now
are left with the political one with the
institutions and
um In fairness the Prime Minister issue
soon okay he's really trying to to
resolve that matter the Windsor
framework I think nearly solves all
those issues there seems to be a few
outstanding ones that have to be
resolved in I hope to meet you the Prime
Minister on Wednesday because this week
in Northern Ireland all of the people
who were involved 25 years ago including
Tony Blair and President Clinton and
Hillary Clinton and all will be in
Northern Ireland for the next three days
so hopefully we'll have a chance of of
you know being able to communicate with
each other
well as one
as one act of that agreement and you'll
as you say you'll be meeting with uh the
other people who made this happen will
there be a tinge of disappointment uh in
that group you Clinton bled so on that a
quarter of a century on
the devolved government is still in a
balance
yeah that is a disappointment Trevor it
it's um you know we we set up the system
based on on power sharing uh where
everything has to be agreed on the
cross-community basis now the the
problem for us that that's that's been
difficult
um and if one side are unhappy with
something they can pull out now that's
what we at the top of your piece there
you said where I said there shall be a
review I I think you can't have a
situation in democracy you know that
every time somebody is unhappy with
something that they can just pull down
the institutions you can imagine if that
was to happen in Westminster or happen
in dollar and
um so we have to try and find a way of
dealing with that and you know if we've
brought it down in different things over
the years and the last time when
champagne were involved they came down
over cash for ash which was an
environmental uh Grant system at this
time it came down effectively over
initiative to do with brexit but we have
to try and find a way that it only comes
down when there's elections and we have
to find a resolution that but it has to
be done in across Community basis
Northern Ireland is still a divided
Society we've made a lot of progress but
there there still are our problems of of
integration and
um so when we we make any fundamental
changes if it's not across Community
consensus in my view anyway everyone
doesn't agree with me that it has to be
done by agreement and it's the only way
we'll make progress but that is the
disappointment I think I'm happy with so
many so many things we did 25 years ago
but the institutions not been up and
running is very unsatisfactory
well you know one of the I guess your
triumphs was that um you had to deal
with what I suppose many people would
say is one of the most difficult
Personalities in Irish politics indeed
politics anywhere the reverend in
Paisley and you got it across the line
um bearing in mind that experience what
would you be saying to his successes in
the dop now when they say we're just not
going back into the institutions until
we get our way on for example the
protocol
well your politics is the art of
compromise and I dealt with the late
David Trimble for a long time and as
you've said the lady in Paisley and all
the time we were able to make the
progress because we were prepared to
compromise
um
then you've had you know first Minister
Mr Robinson come in and with uh Martin
McGinnis and you know I I think we Peter
Robinson Mark McGinnis I think Randy
institutions very very well and it was
on the base as a compromise was on the
basis of of trying to see where they
could get a middle ground and you know
you you do not make much progress in
politics if you don't do that and I
think we have to get away from you know
that this is the position I know what
the position is satisfactory I mean it's
not tenable they're sustainable and it's
not in the interest of the people in
Northern Ireland there are huge issues
in Northern Ireland as there is
everywhere else
including here in Dublin but you know
the only way because I I can't let you
go away without asking a question which
I respect our viewers in Ireland would
like to know the answer to there have
been a lot of presidents wondering about
the British Isles in the last couple of
weeks and more to come with Clinton's on
um now the Irish President Michael D
Higgins will step down in 2025 I I note
that you've recently rejoined uh your
Fiona foil party
um are you going to be the Party's
candidate for president next time around
um I remember the councilor State Trevor
and I I work I'm advised the president
whenever he seeks Our advice
um he's two and a half years to to run
and a big support of the president and
traditionally in our protocols we don't
get into that issue until about five or
six months before the election so so the
answer to that is all in the future
I'm not hearing a no
thank you very much Mr Ahern
thank you for Trevor and good morning to
you good morning to you
Lara McKee was just 29 when she was
murdered by terrorists while reporting
on riots in Northern Ireland
Christians gathered to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
I'm very pleased to say that we are
joined by lira's Sister Nicola to talk
about her life and Legacy good morning
Nicola
Trevor
um lira is being awarded a posthumous
medal tomorrow can you tell us a bit
about that please
so um the chancellor of Queen's
University Belfast who is uh Hillary
Clinton she has
um
been asked to give Leah a medal a
Chancellor's medal and it's for
recognition for the Civic services that
Anne Lear was involved in during her
lifetime here and for the work that she
did
um to try to encourage peace and a
greater inclusion in our society
uh if I'm gonna say Nicola I understand
this is uh not always the easiest
conversation for somebody in your
situation
um so please take your time
um
would you mind for those
viewers who are not completely familiar
with the story telling us what Lira was
doing and how
she met her end
well Lira was an investigative
journalist she began
um her career in journalism when she was
very young when she was about 15 she was
involved in a children's charity called
children's Express
um where they work with young people
from all different backgrounds across
community and encourage them in the
fields of the media and it was
journalism that lira found a love end
and so she
um wrote stories became excuse me Sky
young journalist of the year
and she was very interested in listening
to the real life stories of the of the
people around her the people in society
the people who weren't being heard and
weren't being listened to the Working
Class People
um victims of violence in our society
victims of suicide their families and
she was interested in looking at those
things but she was also interested in
looking at
um the division within our own country
and looking at how
um quite often the political
Representatives
are responsible for the continuance of
that division by stoking up sectarianism
and different things like that so she
was really trying to expose
um
what was really happening for people at
the time of
um her death she was investigating The
Disappearance of young boys who had gone
missing during the troubles here in
Northern Ireland and the police had
um obviously looked into it but had not
launched the investigation that perhaps
they would have launched had it not been
for the distraction of the troubles
which of course you you will know that
um people were being killed quite
frequently
um shot The rebalmings Happening Here
and so the resources within policing
were
um being targeted towards
trying to deal with with that violence
and there was very interested in the
story of these boys because she wanted
to be able to bring
their family's closure because they had
gone out to school in the morning and
didn't come home that evening no one
ever saw them again once they were at
the bus stop and and those boys and
other young people like that
have never ever been recovered and we
never hear those stories Lair was
interested in the stories that we never
get to hear about because nobody seems
to want to tell those stories and they
were the people that she was interested
in at the time of her
um murder
uh she was
in Derry London Dairy she had just moved
there and obviously she was still a
journalist
and as you can see from some footage
from the news at the time
that she was looking at the Right
Through The Eyes of a journalist
and
she
would have been probably very interested
in what would encourage young people to
become involved in that kind of violence
because she was so interested in and the
needs of the working class we're working
class people were brought up in working
class area I still live in the same
working class area not too far from
where Leia was born and she was
interested in the story of our people
because nobody was representing
um The Working Class People and she was
still doing it up until
um the day that she was killed
tragically
Nicola
um
you've described eloquently I think the
body of lira's working
that's partly why she became the young
journalist of the year and I think
everybody who's in who is in journalism
will understand
the quality of that work but she's also
in some way become
I think iconic for young people
particularly in Northern Ireland but
also I think actually in the island of
Ireland uh
what would you
say she would be saying to a young
person who might be interested in
a career in journalism but who has seen
uh
if you like the ultimate downside of her
kind of desire to expose truth
and the danger that some journalists
encounter what would she say to a young
potential journalist now
I think that she would say if you love
it then you must do it
um because I know that she loved it and
that was why she felt the need to do it
and I think that she would encourage
other young people still to become
involved and there is a bursary with the
center for investigative journalists and
the Lea McKee bursary and lots of young
disadvantaged people have
received training in journalism through
that bursary and some of the success
stories emanating from that bursary in
Lara's name have been phenomenal uh
young people getting stories published
and picked up by big
um media agencies and one of the
graduates from the scheme actually
and started their own news platform to
share the stories within their area so I
know that she would be absolutely behind
any young person that wanted to get into
journalism
um I know from our
um history here in Northern Ireland in
our life experience here is that someone
coming out onto a straight at a riot
with a gun is
it's almost
never happened almost never happened
it
it should never have happened but it is
a very very
unusual thing to have happened I don't
think people appreciate how unusual that
was you know these kind of riots and
disturbances are quite commonplace at
different times of the year in our
country unfortunately but someone coming
out a gunman coming out onto the street
is a very unusual
occurrence during a rare of that nature
so I think that
um while Lear was very very mindful of
the risks that she took as a journalist
she still took those risks
because she still felt the need to tell
other people's stories and to enable
their voices to be heard through the
work that she did
Nicola um Sky will be following that
award tomorrow and I think everybody
watching and everybody here at Sky will
be with you in spirit on that uh in the
hope that um out of such an awful awful
moment something good will come as
you've just been describing uh Nicola
thank you so much indeed for joining us
thank you very much Trevor thanks for
inviting me have a lovely day
that is it for this week from Sophie
bridge on Sunday
in a moment after a break we'll run
through today's interviews see what we
learned and I'll be joined of course by
our Deputy political editor samcoat
thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back this is Sophie Ridge on
Sunday the take this morning with me
Trevor Phillips this part of the program
gives us a chance to look back at our
interviews and to try to work out what
we've learned and of course what it
means for the week ahead with analysis
from our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates who joins me now
Sam what uh did you take from our
conversations particularly with Mr hands
and Mr streeting
well we've had weeks of essentially
things going Rishi cnx way in British
politics starting with the brexit deal
over Northern Ireland which comfortably
passed Parliament a few weeks later uh
some successful trips on the world stage
meeting President Biden over in America
and seeing president macron in France
and just a sense in Tory circles that
things were going a little bit better
despite the fact that they're still 15
points behind in the poll but I do
wonder the extent to which what happened
on Friday involving the nurses strike
just as a little bit of unwinding of
that status quo so that was the moment
where one of these strike deals that the
government thought it had struck a
public sector deal uh wage deal with the
nurses of the RCN Union where the
leadership of that Union recommended
they accepted the government deal uh
well the membership the bigger
membership of that Union decided to
reject the pay increase as not good
enough and I think the numbers behind
that vote are really fascinating so the
government as it were the leadership of
the RCN lost that vote 54 voting against
the deal 46 voting for it which is a
narrow margin but here's the thing
Trevor here's what makes it really
interested interesting only 61 of people
who are eligible to vote in that vote
actually took part meaning a real
minority now plunged the NHS back into
chaos you've got strikes coming back
that weren't expected at the end of this
month on the 28th of April for a couple
of days then and the prospect of more
coordinated uh action through the public
sector in the months to come in addition
to school strikes which start once again
a week on Thursday so that carefully
honed reputation for competence that
Richardson was building up well a bit of
that just looks like it might under be
undone by by the subject to the public
sector strikes by the decisions of
public sector uh unions uh just making
people's lives more difficult with no
end insight
well let's get into the detail here
because it's been reported this morning
that the main nurses Union in the RCN
will balance its members on whether they
support a mega strike potentially
affecting hospitals across England
that's a strike which involves all sorts
of people uh at the same time now I
pressed the conservative party chair
Greg hands on the repercussions this
might have
well look I think the public are very
concerned understandably and we will do
everything that we can and I'm sure the
NHS management the NHS will do
everything that it can to make sure that
uh that the impact of the strike is kept
under control but I I wouldn't be being
truthful if I didn't say it will have an
impact a nurse is going on strike it
will clearly have an impact but we think
that we've made a fair and reasonable
offer four percent last year five
percent this year plus lump sum payments
starting at 1 250.
and the shadow Health sector food labors
were streeting we also talked to he's he
says it appears that the Royal College
of Nursing and government are getting
ever further away from settling the
dispute
without speaking for the RCN that's
their job my sense from talking to
members who've been voting in this
ballot is the result that they've cast I
think reflects the depth of anger with
the government and my fear is that and I
hope this dispute is resolved imminently
for this year my fear is we're going to
end straight back here for the coming
years pay round so I think what the
government need to do more than anything
else actually is to give NHS staff some
sense of light at the end of the tunnel
so we're not back here month after month
year after year
and the head of the NHS Confederation
Matthew Taylor explained how the
escalating strikes by the RCN could
impact the Health Service and patient
safety
there are two elements that I think are
particularly concerning to us the first
is the RCN are excluding from derogation
derogation is the way in which trade
unions agree that they will cover
certain
key areas that are involved in
protecting life in limb and the RCN have
said that some of those errors will not
be covered in that x-ray that includes
for example Emergency Services
and we're also concerned about the
speculation that the possibility of a
combination of Junior doctors and nurses
actions so both of these things would be
a significant
escalation and it's very difficult to
see how either of those things wouldn't
endanger patient safety and dignity
uh Matthew Taylor there in a way I think
emphasizing the point you made uh
earlier Sam that we might have thought
that we were heading for a kind of
settlement and some calm Waters and so
on but it doesn't look like that anymore
does it
no and and what's interesting listening
to the RCN this morning listen to
Matthew Taylor there is that it seems
that having got the position of the RCN
the nurses Union leadership in the right
place vis-a-vis the government offer now
the RCN leadership have lost that vote
with their members it does seem like
that RCN leadership Pat Cullen the
leader of that body looks like to be
swinging into a a more truculent more
difficult I'm sure ministers might call
it a more militant uh uh position uh
with a couple of things uh that Gracie
teller referenced first of all there
might be fewer derogations now what that
means in English is that when there is a
strike a few protections to ensure that
if Emergency Care Urgent Care is needed
actually striking workers step in and
then the second thing that looks like
it's going in the wrong direction as far
as ministers are concerned is that it
sounds as if there is now conversation
about not only coordinating strikes but
also this industrial action going
through till Christmas which I think
um whether you're a patient whether
you're a just a veter whether you're
somebody that uses the NHS that just
sounds uh extremely painful Prospect a
point where post covered waiting lists
uh are extremely high so this is going
sharply in the wrong direction and
accompanied by school strikes and other
public sector strikes this has a big
material impact on people's lives worth
pointing out Trevor it was a last week
that we got the growth figures GDP
figures and they were flatlining
precisely because people had been at
home because of public sector strikes
there isn't as much money going to
government coffers through tax revenue
because public sector strikes had been
hit that money which could have been
used for pay settlements not go flowing
into Jeremy Hunt's to Jeremy Hunt's uh
coffers uh it's a there's a danger of a
downward spiral here relations souring
uh industrial action increasing Invaders
have got to work out whose side they're
on well indeed and this is of was the
history of public sector strikes I mean
unlike most strikes the public Sector
Strike everybody has to have an opinion
on because most of us at some point are
going to use a train or a bus or we
might want to use the Health Service or
I you know you've got to take children
to school and so on so it touches our
lives and the the tendency is for
governments to get out there and hope
that in the end the public will blame
the strikers
rather than the government and that the
the unions hope that the public will
blame the government rather than the
strikers uh from your
um extensive knowledge of these things
Sam where does it usually end up
from the moment what's interesting about
the pollings it suggests actually public
sympathy is just nudging a little bit
more in for instance the nurses uh
Direction they haven't yet decided that
the demands of some of the bodies are
unreasonable yes their ministers talk a
lot about the junior doctors 35 uh
demands not clear that they would ever
get that but not clear where uh you
what's the limit at which uh what's the
uh what's the sort of number at which
people sit down around the table
um but I think I think the public
opinion on this is is all to play for
because everybody is facing the cost of
living squeeze that's in part prompting
some of this anger in the public sector
so I think voters are weighing up what
they see in their own lives and the
reasonableness of Demands for public
services all still coming out of the
pandemic uh and the response to the
quite hard-line response of the
government Jeremy Hunt the chancellor
says he doesn't want uh really to do pay
settlements for last year uh that go
above five percent that's why government
departments acting in this way I think I
think one of the interesting questions
one of the difficult questions from
ministers is there are some members of
the government who don't use Public
Services they rely on private provision
uh for health education uh there are
Tory MPS like that as well I wonder
whether that question is going to come
much more sharply into the fall
uncomfortably say for some senior
politicians well if you don't use Public
Services you're not affected by strikes
well of course we're going to actually
get some flavor of how the public is uh
taking taking this and for example the
question you've just raised what they
think about it because in a few uh days
we're going to be
facing the local elections and
conservative party chair Greg hands this
morning conceded when he was speaking to
me that his party faces steep losses but
he isn't giving up the fight
the independent expectations are that
labor the conservatives will lose more
than a thousand seats and that labor
need to make big gains that is what the
expectation is out there okay but I've
been up and down the country the
conservatives were fighting really hard
I've got some great counts you're
predicting a thousand seat loss are you
just trying to massage our expectations
here that is what the independent
experts professors Rollings and Thrasher
John Curtis are all predicting
foreign
what is he doing there when he says oh
well thousand streets gonna happen I
mean in the old days uh he could be
certain to get the sack for that
couldn't he he seems rather relaxed
about it
I think I'm a bit more relaxed about it
too I I felt a bit more like classic
pre-election expectation management look
what Greg hands was doing was digging up
Skye's own election analyst Michael
Thrasher he wrote a piece a couple of
weeks ago along with uh calling rallins
uh in which she was looking at some of
the numbers implied by polls and how
that might turn out in the local
elections and he suggested uh Michael
Thrasher suggested there that you could
see Tory losses of around about a
thousand seats uh labor gains of around
about 700. look this is quite a big
moment for Richie sunax the first test
he has had at The Ballot Box and because
of the way that local elections work and
some councils up some years some
councils up the others this is actually
one of the more important one for
conservatives I think the Tories are
defending uh they've got 85 councils
that they're in full control of and I
think people will be looking to see
whether they start losing control of
those councils not just in uh non-air
urban areas but uh but elsewhere as well
and we'll be looking at the kind of
composition of how the votes shake down
in other words is it the case that labor
is doing better in the red wall is it
the case that the Tories are losing not
only in some of the areas that they won
for the first time in 2019 but it also
in some of those historically
traditionally conservative areas now in
the event that the tillries do badly
they'll say that local elections are no
predictor for the general election which
is expected either the spring or the
Autumn of next year but I think they'd
love to claim something slightly better
than that because I don't think that
anybody's first Judgment at The Ballot
Box any prime minister would like that
to be a damning one well that's right
that's definitely uh one to watch and by
the way Rawlings and thresher you know
how old I am Sam when I first started
covering local elections 40 years ago
Rawlings and Thrasher were doing it then
I mean these are these are the top line
uh these pollsters
um but do you do you think that in
reality that uh these local elections
are really going to tell us anything
will they for example tell us anything
about the impact of Labor's um online
attack ads and the controversy over that
I'm not sure that the labor social media
attack ads had very much reach up and
down the country they seem to be a
phenomenon largely on Twitter and that
seemed to be larger Westminster
conversation but do these local
elections matter well let's see what the
results are but there's one big
difference between how they work
normally and this year which is that the
elections take place on the Thursday
Sky's results program which you'll be
watching will take place on the Friday
but Saturday is the coronation
effectively putting to an end or
certainly pausing the political
conversation about the Fallout from
those local elections so there's going
to be have to be some pretty big
decisive dramatic messages sent by the
voters for them still to be of interest
the following week and to have more
repercussions the fact that Rishi cnx
challenges within the conservative party
really have been somewhat uh somewhat
muted after their defeats on brexit uh
uh I think that does mean that
Richardson is in a stronger place and of
his own in his same position making it
easier probably for the Tories to get
away with a bad result
okay well that's it from Sam but you can
see lots of Sam on those local elections
in a couple weeks time but from this
morning that's it from Sophie Ridge on
Sunday the take